all right my friends you all saw the
state of the union i assume because we
were here and we were drinking and
lauren southern was drunk and she yelled
and called biden based because he said
we got to secure the border that's true
uh so the reason i bring that up in the
context of this story about biden's new
billionaire's tax is that joe biden
during the state of the union says he's
a capitalist
secure our borders
build built make it make america you
know build american
now
after that's long passed he comes out
with this far left 20 minimum tax on
households worth more than a hundred
million dollars this is a trojan horse
marked by words
regular people are going to be like why
do i care i don't make 100 million
dollars
two things they will lower the threshold
like they did with the income tax
initially what was the initial the
initial income tax was like three
percent only for the ultra wealthy right
and then of course they just move it
down move it down move it down but this
is also joe biden desperately pandering
to the far left after calling himself a
capitalist he's like
i wonder if they're doing a media
strategy of
okay state of the union was this big tv
thing that old people watched
say what the old people want to hear now
internet medium put out a statement
that's what the left wants to hear the
progressives so he's going to tax the
rich
they say 20 minimum tax on unrealized
gains
so elon musk that this is this is the
craziest thing it's basically like
if you buy
check this out used cars have gone up in
value like crazy because the chip
shortage
let's say this tax was a general tax on
everybody on realized gains tax you buy
a used car for two grand but then the
chip shortage hits and now the value of
used cars in all government metrics is
up 100
your 2 000 car is now 4 000 the
government goes you got a 2 000
unrealized gain right there and you say
well i don't have any money i just have
my used car and they say then you got to
sell the car yep to pay the tax you say
but if i sell the car then i won't be
able to work and they're like then
you're going to be in trouble for not
paying your taxes so you sell the car
guess what you could only get a couple
grand for the car and they say now you
owe us taxes on the income you got from
that two grand
and you're like so i got to pay the tax
on the unrealized gain but then i sold
the car and i got to pay taxes on the
income right now it's 100 million
dollars
but rest assured you give them the
ability to tax unrealized gains two
things are going to happen one they'll
lower the threshold and the second is
inflation will push you up further and
further to that threshold yeah no it's
true this is one of the most insane
economic policies that he could try to
implement right now first of all we're
not in a place where you can really talk
about introducing these like radical new
measures to socialize the economy first
of all we're not really in a healthy
place so to look at these sort of more
social justice-y far-left pandering
options for policy and try to implement
them as ridiculous but also what this
effectively does tim you know you're
using the example of a used car
it would force people who are
successfully running businesses to the
point of making them profitable to sell
off their shares so basically somebody
who is moving a company in the direction
of making it more profitable is forced
to give up control of their company so
they can pay the tax on unrealized gains
and what an unrealized gain is by the
way
is money you literally have not made
it's completely theoretical the
government is taxing something you don't
have yeah and and they could they could
theoretically just be like hey sheamus
that shirt a million bucks yeah i mean
exactly how do you like what's the value
of something like that i mean hunter
buying's uh art assessor is going to
assess the value of all this stuff
exactly well that's that's a big trick
to people people don't understand that
you're going to all of a sudden see
billionaires being like that rembrandt
painting
unfortunately nobody wants to buy it
anymore because of the tax so it's only
worth a thousand dollars i actually lost
that money can you write off the
unrealized losses yeah well i i also i
mean i'll give the
the regime uh some credit for
recognizing the moment that we're in uh
i think now more than ever there's an
appetite on both sides of the political
aisle to kind of stick it to some of
these uh billionaires and uh on the
right they're sick of the woke
billionaires who fund all these you know
these non-profits the arabellums that
help fortify elections against us and so
there's a appetite to take it to the to
the billionaire class that uh our people
the trump base i mean we're working
class folks um and and so the
billionaires don't have the same luster
and we don't have the same party anymore
and so there is an appetite there i
think
uh to get some on the on the more
populist right to jump on board with
something on this nature but tim you
bring up a good point where they're not
going to stop there if we give the
government an inch they're going to take
it down to you know the the half a
millionaires to the eventually anybody
that makes 100 100 grand will be
impacted by it or in 50 years when
inflation is really really bad and let's
say a dollar is now a dime so you're
spending 10 bucks on a candy bar you're
spending a hundred dollars you know on a
couple movie tickets or whatever
they also you know lowering the
threshold and inflation is going to get
you closer and closer to that limit well
i think that the billionaires should
wake the hell up though especially you
know the ones that help fund these woke
institutions and the organizations to
get you know eat their esg scores higher
um because they're losing the people
that you know for historically defended
them they lose they're pissing off a lot
of republican voters who've always been
against the increase of taxes they've
been against the you know the punishing
the wealthy but when you're using your
wealth to fund organizations that hate
our country
it kind of pisses off some people and
they see stuff like that and like
well right now it's only for the
billionaires so maybe i'll support that
but you know what i think a lot of the
billionaires know that ultimately this
tax is going to disproportionately
affect wealthy people who aren't lucky
enough to be in the exact bracket that
billionaires are in and therefore will
have a more difficult time avoiding the
increased taxes on their net worth i'm
sure they'll find all sorts of
workarounds and loopholes so that they
don't end up having to pay and it will
actually make business more difficult
for their competition this is probably
good for that so i think it's probably
good for them take a look at like the
progressive tax brackets what's what's
the highest bracket is it 250 and up or
is like 500 i need to double check i
think someone changed
yeah so imagine this like 37.5
imagine you're you're a middle-class you
know working-class person and uh you
you hit it big somehow and all of a
sudden you're making 400 thousand
dollars a year which is a lot of money
you're paying a very high tax rate on
that two on everything above 250 which
is substantial it's you know what is it
like 40 was it 38 to 40 something
percent
yeah like 38 38.
if you're if you're worth if you're
making 10 million dollars a year as like
the ceo of a company and you're paying
that percentage
everything after 250 is effectively
disposable income for you to invest any
way you see fit
if you're making 250 to 400
you're like this is my chance to grow
and become a wealthy american but
they're pulling you down
so the simplest way to explain it is if
you only need in the united states right
now 150k a year to be considered middle
class median and that's because of
inflation used to be 77 000 and 80 and
who knows where it's at now
once you hit that threshold you're
getting a savings you're building a
little bit of wealth but you're not on
track for independent wealth where you
can just dump money into a bunch of
funds and then make interest and things
like that you make 10 million dollars
who cares look i got my 250 a year to
fund my lifestyle and then i've got an
extra you know 9.75 million oh i got to
pay 38 i still got 5 million where i can
spend that on any anything i want and
generate massive amounts of wealth
as you as the richer you get the less
that impacts you so the long story short
of it is these taxes
stop people from becoming wealthy now
you tell that to the left you explain it
and they say
good and i'm like no you don't
understand it means the billionaires
will stay billionaires forever and
they'll become oligarchs and then no one
can rise up and displace them and
challenge their power yeah exactly and
so another thing that he's failing to
take into account here and of course he
is because he's on the left is a concept
known as the laffer curve so i've talked
about this on your show before and there
are some less educated lefties who will
say the laffer curve doesn't exist it
does every left-wing economist agrees it
exists the only debate is whether the
parabola peaks at a higher tax rate or a
lower tax rate
basically yeah sure so if you tax at
zero percent your revenue will be zero
and if you tax it a hundred percent your
revenue will also be zero because no
one's going to work for money that they
can't keep so
that means that somewhere between zero
percent and a hundred percent
is the revenue maximizing tax rate at
which point you can reach it and then if
you tax any further you're actually
going to generate less revenue
and so interestingly federal revenues
for the united states have as a whole
have basically stayed around 20
regardless of what the tax rate has been
which suggests that's probably the
largest share of gdp
that they're able to pull and when i
said 22 i'm speaking as a share of gdp
so that's probably the largest share of
gdp they'll be able to pull out of the
economy so all they're going to be doing
with something like this if it even is
effective at getting these people to
sell off their wealth because again who
knows many of them are going to be able
to circumvent it but but let's say it
has its you know quote unquote intended
effect in that way
it's probably not going to increase
revenue i would argue that it wouldn't
increase revenue because the trump tax
cuts actually led to an increase in
revenue the left continually claims that
it didn't and biden talks about this you
know quote unquote fiscal mess that
trump left him but that's complete
nonsense federal revenues increased but
our spending growth outpaced the
increase in federal revenues so we ended
up with more of a deficit after the
trump tax cuts than we had prior but
that was because of an increase in
spending not a deficit in the amount
that we were bringing in
well we just print more print more money
bro yeah
yeah yeah no let's just do that that's
worked fantastically for us they're just
slapping band-aids on band-aids why
don't we start another trillion-dollar
war like multi-trillion dollar war let's
go let's go get a ground war with russia
like adam kinzinger and and lindsey
graham want and get some more money but
um
that seems like the direction things are
going uh i think a majority was it a
majority of americans fear that the us
will go get involved in a ground war
with russia it's it's terrifying
especially i couldn't think about the
the parents who you know have children
who are active duty and they all watch
what the hell happened in afghanistan
and
thinking about the degenerates and the
morons who are in charge right now are
going to be in charge of the military uh
you know the operation on the ground
there
there's not a whole lot of confidence in
their ability to get the job done and so
praying that we can de-escalate and get
peace but
um you know
it's just a mess let's talk about peace
here at home like can i mention one more
thing yeah so you discussed you brought
up biden bingo which we played during
the state of the union address and i
want to mention that that headline
starts with biden whispers that it's not
right which was on the bingo card that
we had that's awesome by the state of
union bingo he likes to whisper daily
mail has some great headlines
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you